توجهنا الى بغداد في هذه المنطقه التي كان
العراقيون يمضون ايامهم وعطلاتهم بها
اصبحت الان منطقه خاليه بل مكان يفتقد
للحياه قبلنا هنا الدكتور عمر الشيخلي
الخبير في منظمه المناخ الاخضر العراقيه
الذي شخص لنا السبب الرئيسيه لجفاف العراق
محملا وزر ذلك الى دول اقليميه يعني خلال
السنوات العاشره الماضيه عن العراق من
شحها مائيه كبيره جدا قد تصل الى الحراج
المائيه يعني الاحتياج الشديد للعراق بلاد
النهرين انه يدخل لاراضي كميه من المياه
همم من حوضين دجله والفرات من الجانب
التركي والجانب الايراني طبعا هذا الموضوع
بشكل
مباد يعني تاثير تازر ما بين شحات المياه
وما بين تاثير التغيرات المناخيه نتيجه
للسدود التركيه الكبيره بسبب مشروع القابل
22 سنه على طيب لو الفرات تازر ايضا مع
مشروع همم
الايراني مشروع التروبيكال بروجكت همم قل
الحصه المائيه العراقيه بشكل واضح جدا
اضافه الى دخول المياه الى داخل اراضي
العراقيه تاذرت مع وضع التغيرات المناخيه
مثل انخفاء شديد في معدلات الامطار خلال
سنوات العشره الماضيه همم بوجود بقعه
للتصحر ارتفاع معدلات درجات الحراره هذا
ادى جميعا بشكل تازلي الى خفض مراسي
بالمياه في حوض اي دجله والفرات مما يحتم
على الحكومه العراقيه ان تاخذ مجموعه من
الاجراءات خلال السنوات العشر القادمه
خاصه بعد تصريح وزاره الموارد المائيه ان
حوض دجله والفرات يبدا بالشحه
الكبير في مستوى المياه خلال عام 20 30 او
20 40 ممكن ان ينتهي الى حد كبير بعد
وجوهنا والفرات على همم على الارض او على
الواقع خلال هذه الفتره نحن ندخل الان
قمه الجفاف
المهزله الطبيعيه او المهزله البشريه همم
كما ترون نحن في الاهوار الوسطى حول
جانبيه ارض جافه وجافه تماما كانت في يوم
ما جنت عدن هذه المنطقه بتنوع اهل الاحياء
بمرب الجاموس بصياد الاسماك الى اخره
اليوم صياد الاسماك دي يغيرون اماكنهم همم
اسبوعا بعد اسبوع تبعا لنوعيه المياه
المياه زادت ملوحتها في كور في قلب
الاوامر الوسطى الى اكثر من 12 الى الجزء
المليون وكذلك الحال في منطقه الحمار
الغربي واماكن اخرى